yeah yeah
Frank
hello hello
[Music]
no I know but what is that picture of it
wow just has a shirt for no reason off
that's off why is that off why would
that be off a shirt for no reason dude
I'm never a guy who wears a shirt for no
reason and honestly the shirts came in
this is important shirts came in this is
important it's not a re-recording yeah
oh well what the [__] don't say swear
words in the beginning right I didn't
mean to
shirts came in
shirts came in if you listen to two
episodes ago
call the okay blank call the cops I'll
have blank with them
there we go
floating in the worst CGI of all time
um yeah dude so that's so we have the
um Tweety Bird
uh I don't know the Tweety Bird Tweety
Bird oh yeah Tweety Bird
um and so that's what's that's what's
going on now and it's episode 75 Sunday
September 17th uh and Sundays are for
Lifeline you know that uh you can go
sign up at Lifeline luxury uh sign up to
get the lifeline luxury patreon.com
Lifeline luxury that's been killing
lately
um so uh a new episode is out Lifeline
luxury go sign up for that and uh you
can go catch me on tour I got a bunch of
different dates coming up here uh we got
um let's see Pittsburgh Cleveland
um and Detroit Orlando Florida Fort
Myers Florida Richmond Virginia
Baltimore Maryland Philadelphia and
Reading Pennsylvania
um kristalia.com for tickets if you have
a question click the link in the
description below or go to watch
lifeline.com or leave us a message on
the hotline down below
um yeah send us videos dude we love the
submissions you want one-on-one advice
sessions with Matt go to mattdelia.com
right go there go to mattelia.com and if
you want the greatest merch that there
is go to
lifelinemerch.com the greatest merch
that ever lived get your pieces that go
with all the other pieces and wear them
all at once when you leave the house
because you never know if there's going
to be a fire in your house or someone's
gonna Rob your house make sure you wear
every piece of merch every time you
leave the house pretty weird pretty
weird but agree
um so something's going on we got these
shirts on and you know what something
else about shirts but go ahead I got
something else you got something else
about shirts yeah but okay well uh Marco
over there said yo it's so weird to see
you in a regular t-shirt because I'm
always wearing like kind of either
different older vintage or also uh
fashion stuff yeah you never wear
vintage stuff but yeah I do I do okay
okay okay so okay yeah okay I'll believe
you I have a one I have a Ducks
Unlimited shirt and then I also have a
motorsport shirt yeah
um and so uh
so that's so but now I have a regular
shirt on and what I'm realizing is nope
I'm beefed out dude
the shirt's too small oh and it's an
extra large so I'm beefed out yeah so
that's why I said we gotta get gotta
make sure we get excels because always
when you get a cheap shirt like this
they run tiny is this the other thing
you wanted is that we want to say about
the other thing I want to say about
shirts is that Anthony wears t-shirts
all the time and he every time someone
asks him about his shirt yeah not only
does he not know the answer but he acts
like it's a ridiculous thing I don't
know to even yeah to even like know what
might be on one's shirt it's absolutely
insane to just be wearing a shirt and
not know anything about it I think I I
and a lot of people I'd say most people
I agree unless you do that like you it's
even it's like not even not knowing the
brand yeah like if you have that thing
on the front of your shirt yeah and it
says a word right and then there's a
picture of it yeah and I have no idea
what the correlation between the word
and the picture is what the word is what
the pictures of right like what did you
just like literally roll on a bunch of
clothes and one thing ended up on you
and you're like oh it's all good I'll
wear this dude I we I I was talking to
Harlan Williams the other day bragging I
mean you know bragging it's not bragging
if you're more famous than the person
right well Harlan Williams is pretty
Legend he's been around for a while and
he is legendary you're right so that is
true not yet he dropped his name
you basically said I know Harlan
Williams because it's Harland right with
the D yes it's also very obvious that I
would know him because he's a comedian
who works so it's not really bragging so
uh he had on a shirt with uh the ghost
um
uh Mario from Mario Brothers like that
you know what that white ghost oh
there's like a ton of different ghosts
and you can okay oh oh in Mario Kart the
ghost yeah that one whatever that is yes
I do know it yeah yeah and um
I said oh you said it all wrong well
what the how the hell would I say the
character in Mario Kart that is a ghost
why are you saying Mario Kart it has to
do with Mario Brothers nobody says Mario
Kart dude there's also on Mario drive
him and you drive in the in the in the
uh uh you drive in the ghost you are the
ghost but that's not what the thing is
from the thing is
it Mario won nobody from the Mario Karts
for me yes dude what does it look like
then
oh oh yeah dude so get out of here with
your Mario Kart it's all good but it
says three okay okay which is a decade
before marrow car probably even longer
oh yeah for sure okay for sure oh yeah I
do remember yeah that thing scared me so
anyway well I must have blocked it out
of my head yeah what's so
um
I know that I don't want to get
demonetized so I know that so you're a
wussy boy um so he was wearing a picture
a shirt with just that on it like this
cool big okay right and I was like oh
you got a Mario shirt on because Eric
Griffin also had a Mario Brother shirt
on oh now Eric Griffin where you know
why he's wearing a Mario Brother shirt
dork he likes we don't know why Helen
Williams is wearing a Mario Brothers
okay yeah especially just the ghost so I
said what are you doing wearing that
yeah you got Mario Brothers you guys
were wearing Mario Brothers says oh is
this Mario I have no idea
you know how it does and I was like you
really don't and he was like yeah I
don't know I was like well then why are
you why do you have it he said I don't
know I just went on and I got it online
and I said like how and he said I just
typed in silly shirts and bought a box
oh my God yeah
and I silly dude and I said you
literally Googled silly shirts and he
said yeah I said why yeah and he said
because I got a podcast I like to wear
different shirts on the podcast I mean
that's pretty smart honestly I feel like
I don't know what to wear I'm a comedian
I like to be silly I'm just gonna google
silly shirts and buy the first 10. so
what's more important to you then when
you're wearing a shirt what is on the
shirt or how the shirt fits
because I would never buy something that
I don't know how it looks on me unless
unless it's a brand that I know or it's
a brand that is similar to another brand
that I know but like just willy-nilly
buying a shirt like this I would never
do it yeah of course we bought it for
jokes on the podcast I
you mean are you basically saying you
would never buy something without trying
it on first no oh okay I mean I guess
kind of except for the fact that I'm
saying like there are Brands I know that
I know how they fit so yeah no I would
definitely do that I I care more about
how
they feel on me not even so much how
they interesting it's how they feel on
me right like this shirt for example
feels like absolute
dog [__] you know what I'm saying and I
might have been a little early for that
but it's okay no it's not okay um uh I I
don't think it feels that bad honestly
really yeah I don't it feels just like a
little I mean I'm sure if we would just
watched it yeah you watch it you know
you let it run we let it Rumble and
Tumble rumbling tumbling trust and God
oh my god wow wow when the earth goes it
takes around Mullen trust in God
knows what percent of the listeners
think do you think know what you're
doing right now I don't know we
definitely talked about it one episode
pretty hard one I've also talked about
it a lot on my podcast
Gregory News Network coming to you from
Jacksonville Florida well oh when Earth
takes the tumble
worst news update ever you know
uh just singing a terrible song the
newscaster made up he was the first Alex
Jones to be honest
um but yeah I hope he's doing well over
he's over in Florida somewhere uh oh
he's dead dude that's what I think and
every time I Google him he's still got
videos pumping out and I'll be in
Florida I hope y'all see him in Fort
Myers or Orlando crusade.com Starbucks
he's just at a Starbucks in Fort Myers
live yeah yeah just uh what a guy dude
you know what's interesting
when you do the impression it sounds
like you're making fun of
an entire group of people but what the
reality is is that that's exactly how he
sounds why do I sound like I'm making
fun because it sounds like just like a
typical thing that when people are
making fun of people with disabilities
and now what I'm pissed about is that I
obviously meant that well because when I
say things that mean in the obvious
thing yeah and why do you ask what
because I I didn't get it because he
doesn't have a uh like a uh I think what
you're getting at is there's some sort
of uh like down syndrome thing I'm
making fun of no no no no no no because
he doesn't have that that's why I was
contestant he has great so we're done we
got it that's not the only way to have a
mental disability Down syndrome is that
okay so what's the disability that you
think I'm making fun of what I'm saying
is the sound the voice that you did yes
makes it it sounds like the voice people
do look at the common for a catch-all
way I don't think it does it does and
I'm listening to it and you're saying it
so it sounds different in your mouth I
don't think it does no what I'm doing is
a legit impression of the guy and it
sounds like let me ever finished I would
have said
you actually didn't even know about so
I'm so mad wow wow wow dude the whole
thing I was saying was it sounds like
yes that but that is actually what
you're doing is an actual exactly right
impression of that but you did say that
I didn't cut you off you did say that
okay see the pistometer the piss meter
is broken yeah the top of the thing
broken exploded from this spouted out
yeah you did it it's your fault okay I
feel like your piss meter probably
broken a lot anyway because they get
pissed at a lot of stuff maybe but dude
anyway I look at freaking beefy in this
shirt let's get to some submissions huh
but I do look beefy in this shirt right
it's pretty crazy you look pretty beefy
I mean so weird beautiful not beautiful
no not beautiful at all Lenny Kravitz
walking down the street Chris
a homeless guy so you guys wanted some
clarification on the drive-through
incident so I'm gonna try to recreate it
for you here as best I can yeah this guy
called me what is it yeah he did but
what was it what was the drive-through
thing he told a girl that she was pretty
in a drive-through right oh and we
wanted clarification thank you so much
dude wow what a good guy
the gloves you know they're so hot he's
great he's great don't mind my dog in
the background if she's screaming no
it's cool well it's not cool if she's
screaming so yes so I she hands me my
food I say
uh thanks uh by the way you're
incredibly pretty and then she goes
oh okay
and like you know wants to leave
obviously
and I'm like
I'm sorry I I'm I'm not trying to be
weird
and uh she's like
okay well
uh enjoy your food oh I was like thanks
see ya and then I just drove off yeah
very simple nothing crazy happened
genuinely I believe all the detail there
is really yeah right um I was also
really intoxicated baffled in the in the
moment that like I really you were a
little shook too yeah you know it just
happens and they just don't really
capture the whole memory
um but it wasn't even really a big deal
at the end of the day it was just kind
of like
it was just a jarring response and I
thought maybe I was missing something
entirely but yeah at the end of the day
it's not that big a deal yeah oh this
guy's great but I wanted to ask you guys
a new question
and my question is
should you say bless you or should
someone say bless you when you sneeze
personally I don't really like what
people say because then I have to kind
of respond and say like hey thanks you
know or like be like oh like thanks like
I don't I don't need to be blessed I
just sneezed it's fine
um sometimes I actually try to really
avoid sneezing especially in the
workplace so that nobody has to say
bless you to me that's great
um maybe that's strange but it's a bit
Yeah so how do you guys feel about that
uh once again love the podcast thank you
and I'll see you guys later
yeah when I someone sneezes I just go
like this great
no when someone sees I go like I say
bless you but I do it under my breath so
they don't have to say thank you but I
did it for the world why would you do it
though it's just a non thing no I say
bless you all the time to somebody I
don't think
it's always been weird though because
it's a religious bless you yeah it's
gone it's transcended that though
obviously it's not it's not a religious
thing yeah just so you know everyone
does that they're not like super
religious the literal words are weird to
go along well I don't was it because
people thought like that was the devil
um in you like bless you no it's because
when you sneeze your heart stops and you
die a little bit they think no yeah
really your heart stops your heart skips
a beat and they go oh you were close to
heaven or hell so bless you but I don't
say God bless you I say bless you
because I'm the one blessing you
is it even God bless you is that God
bless you yeah oh wow wow it's so dumb
yeah no it doesn't bother me though yeah
but uh that's weird that it bothers you
and that is something that the kind of
thing that would also bother me but that
doesn't that doesn't bother me I go like
this what you could do is I bless you as
as you're like you could be like guys
I'm about to see don't say bless you
listen yeah true and then sneeze yeah
but here's the number one thing is if
someone says Gesundheit you get to choke
them out yeah but that is obvious
there's inside what oh god
uh yeah also that heart stop when he's
dancing sounds like [__] but
somebody said that to me
hopes that prayer would protect them
from an otherwise one of the symptoms of
the plague was coughing and sneezing and
just believed that Pope Gregory Gregory
the Great suggested saying God bless you
after our person sees in hopes that the
prayer would protect them from and
otherwise certain deaths oh okay all
right so it's some superstitious yeah
yeah yeah it's idiotic yeah so great I
spread misinformation wow that's okay
the pope it's the pope I'm Alex Jones
Pope Gregory dude one thing we can
always rest assure whoever the pope is
is pretty pretty superstitious yeah yeah
I mean have you seen the way he's
dressed
BS hat you know yeah well no Cardinals
have big ass hats Cardinals have the
best outfits of them all I should dress
like a card hope is dressed cool but
Cardinals pull up a cardinal
why are they all in St Louis or Arizona
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah hey did it
Cardinale a day what that's not what we
want that's the Cardinal of the bird the
Cardinal it is yeah Cardinal Church hey
religion
I mean he typed in cardinal bird type in
Catholic cards
sorry okay you're fired oh wow you're
just fired
let's stop for a second
also why even add bird if he thinks that
that's the only one I don't understand
you guys were talking about
you guys are basically saying that I was
gonna type in the sports team yes yeah
yeah yeah and I was like oh well
obviously he means the bird then not the
sports team
I didn't know that Cardinal hopes
existed kind of Pope
[Music]
another position it's a lower it's like
uh it's like there's the president and
the bunch of senators and they're like
senators of the Vatican all right so
Cardinal outfits are go go up so what
else you want to do is click on the
image is what you'd want to do is click
on images right images and then any of
the images
you know
that's the heat is on dude you better
click on the right one
that you did the right the right one
good job good job yeah it's pretty good
13 Cardinals wow they always hug with
their arms down like this like touching
their arms and not over because they
can't reach because the thing they have
the things on it right right the
frontward's case also if they lift up
their arms you'll see that they're all
naked under there dude those hats
[__] suck you know everything about
you know it looks like a [__] uh a
box that you'd put your takeout in
everything about can I get a box to go
and they give you the Cardinal hat the
way
the Catholic
organization the church the the religion
I the religion eyes the organizer
Anthony of Catholicism the way that they
dress the higher ups is so
[__] stupid you know what they should
wear these get over it like I'll have
sex with them get with the times dude
look at the guy's hat to them it's like
it's a Bento Box
his name was Pope Benedict of course
yeah they all look the same he wore
Christian Louboutin shoes oh that was
real
oh you know not what the pope should be
standing for you know and I'm sorry if
you're Catholic and you're listening I'm
not but if you're Catholic and you're
listening why he's still Catholic yeah
but yeah that's true why does the
football wear red shoes because he's
because he's got that drip on him
honestly
he's trying to keep the nuns we pass out
towels with the nuns wow that's kind of
cool though you can wear whatever you
want you could wear whatever you want on
your sh on your feet so he's got to
express himself many of you had Yeezys
on
um anyway
well nothing is more religious than you
know it's the Latino Shoemaker right so
he's probably like please please the
pope now where am I what what are you
pointing at the Latino Shoemaker had
said it was a little did you know
Shoemaker that made those shoes
anyway please please for us for us for
us for the people we need you know uh
anyway all right cool I did an Italian
accent but wait I have this wrong he
just wore red shoes ah [__] me man bam
dude wow just but they oh they were
Prada
they were proud of red shoes okay which
is a classic Prada thing right they do
those red shoes I don't know I don't
know we honestly this podcast there have
been no facts so far we've been saying
things Cardinal out of our cardinal bird
you know cardinal bird your heart stops
when you sneeze yeah and he's running
Louboutins I haven't said a single piece
of misinformation and I'm proud of that
um you will all right all right next one
well Chris and Matt Chris I came to your
show a couple years ago in Chicago it
was a New Year's show good ass time
um anyway the topic is he's legit I've
never seen somebody with the same hair
on his chin as on his head if you just
switched it it would look exactly the
same that's incredible I've never seen
that
that's incredible it's pretty yeah also
the most regular shirt I've ever seen in
my life okay just regular guy to a t
this guy I was listening a couple year
old Lifeline episodes and Chris you were
talking about how you just had a hard
time at weddings yeah and uh that's
exactly why I feel one of my weddings
doing like I just feel out of place I
feel like a misfit like why is everyone
here having such a good time I'm just
over here you know totally not
um so anything you have for me I didn't
really go to weddings or dances or
anything come up as a kid uh deeper
um so yeah anything Matt Chris anything
you guys got me any advice on how to
have a good time and just uh enjoy the
wedding uh let me know I'm in a wedding
in a few weeks in Vegas
love what you're doing take it easy
thank you I appreciate you I'll tell you
this much my whole attitude has changed
uh uh uh when I'm at events now I'm way
better at them I think it's because the
CBD I take from Pure Spectrum I can go
get on the code uh you type in the thing
and you click on Wow uh congrats but
that [__] helps and that's why I'm in
business with them I'm not saying you
should do that but my point is I think
that that's what helps for me also dude
I feel like
um
the uh
uh I mean wow what's going on yeah I
feel like he uh your your inch you're
you don't like going to weddings you go
into Vegas and being in a wedding that
could be a good
you know I know he's obviously been to
some weddings but that could be a good
way to ease into it is because it's
Vegas it's not like you're in the middle
of nowhere [__] you know in Indiana
which I'm you know what I mean just like
I assume the wedding's still going to be
wedding-ish though but you mean like no
yeah yeah that's what I mean like at
least it's just that and then also
although maybe it's not going to be
weddingish if it's in Vegas
yeah like why the [__] would you be
wedding ish if you're gonna be in Vegas
but he's also in
the weddings who's gonna have a bunch of
[__] that sucks to do yep having a
wedding is rude having a wedding is
insanely rude yep thanks for being
here's here here's what's even more room
thanks for being in both of mine having
a wedding
then there's like 250 guests thanks for
did that twice you know who that's rude
to about 230 people been rude to 500
people every time a little under because
some of the people at those weddings
want to be there like the person's
family their best friends whatever but
most people
um this goes out to everyone who's
listening who's ever been married plans
on getting married or might one day get
married at your wedding mm-hmm
just keep this in mind no one wants to
be there yep nobody there wants to be
there except your mom yeah and some
other people who are like you and I get
you kind of have to have a wedding
sometimes I understand you know because
either the woman wants it or sometimes
the guy wants it or they think it's the
right thing to do I get it uh however
definitely keep the actual ceremony
short and the speeches short yeah yeah
nobody wants to hear your speech where
it's just and that's why when we and she
was the only person in class that I I
got along with because we both wore
jellies that's a good speech though that
if it's like that it's okay and that but
that's the best that's the best that's
the top yeah yeah oh dude remember
jellies that's why I said it do you
remember them now you said it a few
seconds ago yeah dude do you remember
jellies Marco that's why I said it does
everyone remember jellies I mean what
the [__] did I thought about jellies in
like
30 years you remember this you jealous
yeah Magellan Magellan is it Magellan no
well Magellan was the was that that was
a part of it right I think I don't think
right I don't know I think I don't know
yes it was it was he said I'm
I'm like Magellan I'm so jealous oh yes
he's right there we go Marco came
through he's usually done but he got it
well they still make him yeah dude oh
they still are a thing yeah I thought
only 8th grade girls in the late 90s
could wear them well that's when they
started wearing that's when they
exploded
people are still doing anything girls in
eighth grade in 1999 we're doing that's
crazy I mean look they're kind of like
honestly they were ahead of their time I
was they're sick I would say they're
they're not like they weren't like that
then those are just no they got a chick
there's men's I'm getting a pair bro I
mean what do you think you got to keep
updating [__] you can't just have to say
right you're right but they're so
different though right no they're not so
different okay yes they are the whole
thing about jellies is they were like
that weird yes material they still are
oh really so yeah look at them I don't
see the material on them though you
can't go up go up see the blue one right
there on the right you can see it oh oh
wait the one on the left isn't like that
oh interesting or interesting that's not
a true jelly to me no you're right but
oh see because that's the kids one
that's why there we go there's another
adult one we've gone to the bottom there
we go so they're not the true jelly ones
yeah no they're not they're imposterous
there we go look at the men's jelly ones
jelly ones oh let's see the guy wearing
them yeah he looks good oh he looks
really bad honestly that guy you want to
fight I could be honest I got not
because of his shoes though you just
want to fight him
uh anyway so jellies yeah cool I said
and I pulled it deep from the archives
to make it funny oh dude I never would
have been able to think of that on mine
but how good was it how I pulled it deep
from the archives to make it funny yeah
you pulled it deep from the archives and
it made it funnier yeah okay
okay okay took it who was the next guy
oh man
hey guys we're gonna take a break right
now to talk to you about something
football is back in full swing with
another epic week of games and who's got
you covered on the action for every
single one of them DraftKings Sportsbook
an official sports betting partner of
the NFL new customers can bet five
dollars on football and get 200
instantly in bonus bets nobody's missing
out on the action this season all
DraftKings customers can take advantage
of two new offers every game day this
September get in on the NFL week two
action with DraftKings Sportsbook
download the app now and use code
Lifeline to sign up new customers can
bet just five dollars and take home 200
instantly in bonus bets only on
DraftKings Sportsbook with code Lifeline
the crown is yours gambling problem call
1-800 Gambler or visit
www.1800 gambler.net in New York call
8778 Hope and why or text Hope and why
that's 46 73 69. in Connecticut help is
available for problem gambling call
888-789-777 or visit ccpg.org please
play responsibly on behalf of Boot Hill
Casino and Resort Kansas 21 plus age
varies by jurisdiction void in Ontario C
sportsbook.draftkings.com football terms
for eligibility terms and responsible
gaming resources bonus bets expire seven
days after issuance eligibility and
deposit restrictions apply
hello Chris and Matt this is Sister
again from
now before answer my question
and unfortunately I am classically
trained so I have all the strums at the
symphony but however I first and
foremost a Latin drummer and drums don't
introduce that my primary Institute our
congas and Bongos I have a great way to
set my phone down hell yeah so these are
conversations big ones
[Music]
the ones my absolute favorite are bongos
Matthew McConaughey played them with his
dick out right whoa
balance I don't keep them set up but
this is with the Rhythm on them
cool and yeah disease streams together
make up the heartbeat of salsa music wow
there's some kakon there's Drumline
stuff showing it to us but yes I'm going
to see you in that show and hopefully
you get the Tweety Bird shirt on time
shirt right now and thanks for coming to
Nashville a Nashville was awesome uh and
then over there yeah that's what she
said yeah so thank you very much
um for coming actually that was a an
unreal that venue dude that venue the
Ryman yeah is is the best venue I've
ever played what yep I know and I didn't
want to believe it because it's built in
1980 uh uh 1896 or something 18 yeah
1800s ancient cool ass ones in Nashville
dude I was like all right well like you
know how you think what did they make
you not want to say it that should make
you want to say it that's crazy like
something amazing as a venue was built
in there no no no no no no no what what
I mean is you know how people say things
are good just because they've been
around for a while no I know that you
think that I don't think people actually
do that though
Matt you don't think people are like
it's like this it's like give me an
example they don't make them like they
used to and in this meantime like yeah
okay oh okay so cool so you'd rather
have a [__] 1950 Chevy oh I see then
a car with all the bells and whistles
and Bluetooth and the air conditioning
and [__] like go [__] yourself you're
not even being right yeah yeah that's
what I'm saying okay okay this venue is
it it's got church pews for seats so I'm
like uh everyone thinks it I'm just
people just believe in the hype is like
to me that's how I am with everything I
go I perform in the dude it was the best
venue I've ever played as a performer at
least I gotta say it was so awesome dude
it's so I'm sitting there and I go out
while Lulu's on stage and I walk out
there for a little bit and I'm in the
crowd and I'm like
what the [__] dude how is it possible
that they make all these venues now and
they're not this good and this one was
made over a hundred years ago yeah
yeah anyway I'm getting off topic here
because she wants to know about the
drums but uh yeah that's cool that you
put the Congress and we were we were
racist I guess because we just think
about those drums and what she did just
like a quick demonstration
I'm not kidding yeah there's no chance I
could learn how to do even the very
first thing she did I'm like the lead
I'm I'm already not musically inclined
like I put me in front of a musical
instrument I have no idea what to do
also singing yeah that too for sure but
I'm a good singer obviously okay well
it's it's the rawness that comes out so
it's different raw is it classically
good no but is it the rawness it is the
rawness okay so but like I I was
thinking when she just said that there's
no way I could do that you could and
here's the drums are the I'm the worst
at uh percussion instruments yeah I
would tell you this much yeah you you
could learn how to do it but however
there's one thing that's for damn
certain you will never be able to do
that do what what you did I know that
it's not that you can't it's just that
you want oh it's not a one there's no
way a matalia would ever be
I want to know how to play an instrument
but not I couldn't [__] with those yeah
what instrument would you play I would
play the violin and do this the Thong
Song all the time the violinism
[Music]
violin huh that's a good choice maybe to
be like I would be like a great person
like a great artist at this instrument
you're saying a great artist like I
would be great foreign I would be a
great artist a great artist is not
foreign
instrument you just said it dude set it
and forget it what did I say you said I
want to learn how to play an instrument
you said that's what started this whole
thing no I didn't
I don't want to learn how to play an
instrument
what I didn't say that did I make that
up Anthony I might have said something
like that yeah I didn't say something
like it I might have said I think you
said that you I mean I could never
that's what we're gonna do we're gonna
run the tape back yeah it's not that you
can't it's just that you won't oh it's
not a one there's no way a matalia would
ever
Beck I want to know how to play an
instrument but not I couldn't [__] with
those yeah I want to know how to play an
those yeah but I think what you said was
that you would like you like the idea of
it or you you want to
be whatever you said dude we don't know
now at this point we'll replay it but no
matter what I said here's what is the
truth if I misspoke or didn't okay uh I
I don't want to because I cannot do it
I've tried to in the past defeated I
wish I had the capability or the mind
for it then I would do it because music
instruments musical instruments are the
[__] but like I don't have a single one
I can even get remotely get the hang up
dude remember when Mom would be like
you're gonna want to learn you're going
to want to learn I'm going to get your
piano lessons you're going to want to
learn you're going to be happy that you
did and I I did piano lessons for a bit
you know yeah I did like two different
teachers and [__] I remember and and
she's like you're gonna Thank Me Not
only not only am I [__] so happy that
I didn't go through with it so I could
learn the piano not only am I so happy
yeah that I quit I'm upset I wasted that
much time it's funny because she should
have made me do it because I feel the
exact opposite I really wish I knew how
to play it yeah dude I wish I knew how
to sit in front of a piano and do
something on it because that's like a
skill that I because what do you mean
why why do people learn how to play the
piano that's why do you want to learn
how to play plates no that's not
something okay roll plates that's not
something twirl plates no no because and
also neither do most people asking me
why I want to know how to play the piano
as if it's a ridiculous thing when
millions of people know how to play the
piano because their mom made them that's
not why people play piano you think that
someone's [__] sitting in a piano bar
and that person's mom didn't make them
do it
uh yeah I think that I said if you look
if you need many many thousands and most
people who pick up the piano okay that's
fine just because their mom made them
I'm just saying deeper I'm just saying I
would really appreciate it if I I wish
I'd never sat I wish I never sat at a
piano bench even for once I wish I knew
how to play the piano even when you
played I was like damn I think that's
cool then why didn't you play dude
because I couldn't do it oh that's like
the fetus I didn't have the the brain
for no I didn't decide I couldn't do it
I tried and couldn't do it you tried for
a little bit you didn't try too much
you're right you're right I didn't Tiger
Woods the whole [__] Endeavor you're
right all right
hey I know that sorry guys I'm just at
work uh to the guys we had on last week
uh here's some advice I can give to them
uh for the Swedish guy who's working in
Australia uh you actually have to claim
that 750 on tax like officially speaking
with that guy yeah so just say to the
lady listen I have to actually put all
tips on tax uh so you have to pay me my
normal wage or else that'll be flagged
uh by the ATO which is technically true
when we could get deported actually did
happen to a friend of mine uh which is a
bit of a mess so the other guy who has
his uh neighbor who's driving into his
parking spot just put a whole heap of
eggs just go down the store grab some
eggs put a whole heap of eggs down your
side of the parking spot just leave them
there ride on them do not move do not
touch and then if he touches them if he
runs over them just leave them a note
being like hey don't touch my ex
hold on what was this parking oh wait
what was it again yeah the guy that is
what was what the what the original guy
called him yeah yeah yeah I think it was
some guys parking in the spot right no
it was some guy's parking badly next to
him in his spot right right yeah but
then what was the eggs thing did this
guy [__] talking he's hiding eggs
don't is that again he loves the eggs
dude he's just adding eggs he didn't
need to add anything but he added eggs
here's what you do go get eggs thanks
this [__] worst guy friends like I
got a headache hey okay I like some eggs
what
ah I'm just gonna put some eggs near you
and there you go your headache's gone
probably some time let me know
because the eggs be like no it's just a
day it was yesterday why did you bring
eggs into this dude he wakes up in the
middle he wakes up the next morning
there's eggs near him he had it gone
wait why
the egg thing made me forget the first
thing oh the the guy the Australian
taxing the tip yeah okay yeah yeah I
didn't hear a word he said about that to
be perfectly honest did you that guy the
the the other attacking thing this guy
that just did that video I didn't hear a
word he said about the whole video yeah
oh that's amazing yeah uh I I don't know
about the the the the taxing thing uh he
has to claim it I guess but that doesn't
change the fact about what the guy this
isn't what the guy was talking about
yeah it's like that may be true right
but like the person the daughter was it
in the last episode right I think so
daughter
like still was being a giant prick yeah
I mean you said something that isn't
what it's about so so you not only said
something about yeah you then brought up
a whole other scenario that another
color called in about wasn't it and
brought eggs in for absolutely no reason
so come on to meet her upon this is that
guy coming with a problem someone else
who knows that guy call in about that
guy and the problems that he causes in
your life because he definitely causes
them but tell me a problem that you have
and then I'll tell you uh this is how
that guy responds to problems yeah
uh I got this like I don't know what's
going on but it's like a painful pain
top of my shoulders down my spine just
like uh sharp pain yeah okay so you know
when like it's summer you got to wear a
t-shirt it's like hold out and then like
as it gets cool You're Gonna Wanna
sweater
what about eggs
also you can eat eggs yeah yeah right
yeah that's true okay I'll try that
yeah that guy's I don't know
I just don't know about the last guy
yeah but I I do like his energy and his
disposition what was he ever talking
about his energy in his disposition
I bet he gets the whole thing of when
people say God I know you from somewhere
I bet that guy gets that so I didn't
know him from somewhere much you thought
you knew him for somewhere and you
didn't I didn't you're right but I
thought I thought I did I actually think
that the guy he looks like he's a guy
that we both know who I'm not going to
mention right okay cool sounds good go
ahead next one
I've got a quick one for you especially
since you both enjoy movies and you're
in the film industry
um I I he his hair always looks so much
better like this okay that's what I'm
noticing what did his hair he had really
long hair and we were like the [__] it
was all flowing oh right and then he
called in again this is the third time
this is the thing you know what you know
what Harry had the hair that that
skeleton has on his shirt I think it's a
hood but that's what it looked like okay
well well terrible okay uh all right
cool I can't get over hair and facial
hair haircuts and movies particularly
the ones better on myself like you know
someone's been gone for a long time or
I'm a devil movie or something I'm
particularly talking about this show
called see what Jason Momo is actually
ridiculously good I feel like no one
watched it but oh it's good it's about
blind peoples
and they have the greatest haircuts and
it's like yeah it's just such a
suspension from like reality I hate that
breaks it for me I guess maybe no one
else gives a [__] but anyway no curious
what you guys think about the hair in
movies
um really line up with what you'd expect
from that era or setting or totally do
it let me know what you think here's
what happens because when you go to set
that cut your hair almost every time and
they make it fresh but and then you're
in like a Middle Ages thing and you
you're just like
you know what I mean all quaffed and
[__] and they're like I'm not gonna live
much longer I have the gout and you're
like your hair is dope and they have
product in it yeah I mean they want yeah
their feet are all [__] up but your
hair is amazing the problem
there's like a this is like a symptom of
like a bigger issue that I have when
people criticize something for not being
realistic they're first of all
no movie that's right history has been
realistic that's one I agree that I
agree with that and so when people buy
but what I'm saying is people Overlook
things like that what do you mean
they Overlook things like this guy's
talking oh got it okay they don't think
of that kind of [__] and they should or
like when some like working-class
person's got a giant New York City
Apartment like that's just taken in
stride because like friends like the
people yeah yeah yeah yeah people lived
in they would have been like 10 million
a month and it's just like these people
are unemployed actors but it's never
addressed you know people say they care
about realism stop pretending you'll
enjoy stuff a lot more realism sucks
nothing is realistic so you're saying
it's okay things no I'm saying
well sure I guess but what I'm saying is
it's a hypocrisy people say they value
realism oh first and foremost and they
absolutely do not nothing about their
[__] I agree I agree I agree uh I I want
to go though and uh
I think that it's okay by the way I'm
bleeding so much myself
I think that um
what I think is that
it it's no movie should ever I don't
like that whole Slice of Life realness
type of movie usually because of that
because let's see how real this is and
it's still fake like nobody's doing what
John cassavetes did obviously I'm saying
like that was just straight up that was
real right and but like
this like
don't make this [__]
you're fighting an uphill battle it's
okay to make it you know you have the uh
who's the guy who did uh the years
Johnny movies uh Stanley Kubrick and uh
you have David Lynch you don't all have
to be like that but those movies are
awesome and they're not real at all and
I love that [__] yes right yes so the
second you're like yeah but realism and
now that's not how it really would be
that drives me nuts that's what people
in movies like oh that wouldn't really
be really that's not how it is oh oh it
isn't yeah no [__] we're watching a
movie movies aren't supposed to be
realistic if they were they'd all suck
but what sucks is a lot of times the
even the filmmakers will do movies like
Transformers and be like yeah but that's
not real enough I know but then that's
that's why those movies are [__]
awful but that's what that's like a
guiding principle of many filmmakers and
many audiences I know and critics and
everything it's [__] like like
totally understandable things to say
Batman it's like it's like dude you
don't have to make this real you know
you know like Batman realistic it's
weird that they please don't it's
[__] Batman it's weird Batman it's
weird that Chris Nolan made and I love
Chris Nolan but it's weird that he may
made this realism Batman and now all
superheroes are like yeah they're in
this real City that this is really
happening and and the Joker doesn't look
like the Joker anymore he's a little bit
you know less makeup and more how real
life Joker would look it's like so odd
to me yeah it's really odd yeah but you
like it though oh I watch it I don't
like them I I the have you watched The
Dark Knight the Christopher Nolan movie
The again oh again yeah again I everyone
says his are the best and they just oh
for sure do not hold up to me it's so
who do you like the best the the Tim
Burton ones you're saying no well those
are great those are awesome but the best
one is the new one I think with Robert
Pattinson oh really oh yeah a hundred
percent geez wow it's so awesome I
didn't finish it so I can't really speak
to it but I was not feeling it when I
was wrong it's so cool he's cool yeah
all right uh I I don't like that I don't
I don't like that at all I agree with
this guy so much it would be like that
guy's hair in like [__] you know Game
of Thrones or I guess the Game of
Thrones doesn't matter because they're
so fictitious but like yeah
um Abraham Lincoln the [__] movie
with what's it called Lewis we'll talk
about realism you know it's like yeah he
probably didn't wash his hair for like I
know it's disgusting disgusting
all right cool
I love you guys both I got a quick uh
Jordan with the slime on the run I mean
how much is it positive how much is this
guy dressed like he did something very
illegal like dealing with money and like
this is how he looks the moment he's he
decided to look different like he cut
all of his hair off he shaved everything
except this little patch of dirt on his
chin he got big sunglasses and a hat and
he had like used to have like long hair
you know and a beard and that's like his
mom's sweatshirt okay go ahead
when we were in high school we were at
the lunch table and our buddy was uh
talking about his piss crank shout out
to Will Sasso for that term
he hit us with a double negative you
know he hit the negative so we thought a
positive was coming and when it didn't
it was the best he goes
you know my uh my piece it ain't the
longest but by golly it is the thinnest
and we we cried laughing for about 10
minutes straight so hard to where you
like you laugh so hard and you know you
can't hear one more funny thing because
you know you'll die literally expire
he'll die so you're like shutting your
eyes and like plugging your ears and so
now whenever we're somewhere then we
like to hit a double negative you know
we'll be eating at a restaurant be like
man this steak
you know it ain't the most season but by
golly it is the driest right yeah so uh
that's I mean I think uh wrong
what do you think his [__] mind what
do I think about what what is that a
Jordan with this line is that a Jordan
what the slime
I wish I had pen and paper to do a
diagram but that is uh zero percent like
it's Jordan okay but why though
um because it
isn't weird yeah it's too much of a it's
out of the glue right it's not a joke
that a guy told you yeah it's a [__]
it's too coherent I'm pissed it's a
[__] people don't really get into
Jordan with their slam it's not just
something that you remember it's not
just see what I'm saying yeah yeah yeah
you were so easy on the guy
but look he's great guy this isn't to do
he's a great guy this guy's a great guy
but he's not getting it right most
people don't get the dog
what are they missing how do we what do
we do they want to make sense I'll tell
you why
this is so
this is so [__] suckery okay but we live
a life of play in the world of Comedy
okay especially me it's not something
you can figure out because it wouldn't
be as funny to us if it was because it
needs to be a little more out there
because we are advanced in comedy so
most people think well I gotta make
sense of it it's got to be funny so it's
a joke it's not it's just something and
now we got people listening right now
that are like I know what it is I got I
got it and you may you might but you
also may not if it makes too much sense
it makes no sense that he kept going
John with the Slime the reason why it
was funny is because it was like why the
[__] yeah is he doing this it made no
sense so now I told Matt and now his you
know Marco we know what tell us what the
Slime is three decades later yeah right
you're right it's it's oh it's not a
non-sequitur because it's much more than
that but in a way one of its qualities
is very non-sequitur-ish it's like when
someone is doing something that is
unclear as to why yeah well and it's
like especially when there's like
bombast and like a weird like sharp tone
of voice to it like he was putting on a
higher voice yeah we didn't know why and
it was like
and then it when it sticks that's all
that really happened with the Justin
mckimmon thing it was like yeah it stuck
because he told us and we thought it was
funny and then we kept doing it over
years it ended up being a thing that we
would do without even thinking about
what it was like we'd see a Michael
Jordan jersey and yeah think it and then
say yes good point I don't like that
that guy said it all that stuff I'm
pissed see you I mean you weren't even
pissed at the beginning hey have you
guys ever spoken to that guy because you
have talked about this so much here on
congratulations like it's just no yeah
that's a good question I I haven't
talked to Justin in a long time he
hasn't dm'd or anything like yes I I
know I saw his social media he's
supposed like six pictures and it's like
a [__] it's always something when you
find the person you're looking for and
you're like yes and then you look and
they haven't posted it's like 2018
you're like no they're never gonna check
yep
a lot of people that you haven't looked
at up in a long time are now conspiracy
theorists yeah well especially because
if you haven't heard from them in a
while then you look under the radar
that's why okay this is why I haven't
heard of them yet
um but anyway uh
I I I re let's just look at the positive
the one of the reasons why I was like I
told him about the Slime is because they
keep doing it and it keeps it keeps
recurring that's what I was going to
give you yeah yeah okay yeah yeah right
but that is maybe that's what people are
missing but it's not just that no it's
not just something you remember and and
with a group that and then it becomes
sort of like an inside joke it's not all
it is it is also that but that's like
the last thing that it is yeah there are
other things that it is I hope people
don't find this Jordan with the slanting
too crazy that they don't that they're
like what is this podcast and flip it
off although people were I can't believe
how much people liked the Jordan with
the slam thing last episode
people like things that people care
about and people like things that are
specific to certain people yeah this is
insanely specific to us and people do
here's the thing everybody does have
stuff like this I know but I think
people that have sent videos and they
don't they're not filing it a lot of
people they don't realize Jordan with a
slam thing and it just labeled the wrong
thing because one of the reasons why you
have a Jordan with the slam thing is
because you realize oh that's a Jordan
with the slam thing and then you tell
each other and you're like oh [__] this
is becoming Jordan with the slam thing
many people I bet do not have that kind
of a thing that it exists in their life
I bet but no you're that's like a
chicken chicken or the other thing what
you just said how like oh no I mean we
don't have to we can call it whatever we
want but it's a Jordan with the slam
thing because Justin McKibben kept
saying McKinnon kept saying don't
bastard Jordan
with the slam and we were like what the
hell is he doing like that is just what
it was like people I guarantee you that
guy but it's not a Jordan with the slam
thing unless then it is repeated and
said oh we did it again and then we did
it with the slam and then in next week
totally with the slam and now it is
solidified itself as a total with the
slime thing well okay okay and I'm very
very very very very very very very
passionate about this I can see that
yeah I can see that all right should we
get one more stop getting them wrong I
don't think there's ever been a Jordan
with the slam thing that people told us
about here's what we want get it right
and make a video and send it it'll be
fun if it's wrong though too it will be
yeah I don't know if it's right yeah
yeah somebody's gonna take a chance and
be like I don't know if it's right and
be right so don't not send it make take
that video and send it we want people to
get it right and we want to see someone
get it right you know eskib
never think about it skip
I don't know it sounds familiar so I
told the story of my podcast but when I
was at I would go to Bob's Big Boy
almost every night I look at the Bob's
Big Boy Burger do you know about that
disgusting yeah I was also 23. why do
you think that's funny oh gonna kick his
ass I think it's funny that he thinks
it's disgusting okay so that you ate a
Burger every day that that is disgusting
is the word and he did it but I was also
23 it's okay wow that's defensive that's
God so
um
so
the guy would come up the the Hawaiian
or Samoan uh
waiter would come up and say we don't
you know like really short okay an
accent yes whatever I would say I wanted
I would mostly get the burger sometimes
I would get the stir fry sometimes I
would get the you know whatever I said
he would say Escape
the house what does that mean I skip
it's skib
I mean I really really leaned in to try
and understand what he was saying never
asks him
no and I really regret it how could you
not I think you know the answer that
question but I will answer it
it was too funny and I wanted to figure
it out myself
but like you didn't figure it out I
didn't but one day
years later
I came up with a really good theory okay
you want to know the worst part about it
you forgot it completely and I don't
remember what the theory was and I was
so sure that that's what it was and now
I'm pissed off and how much do you hate
when people say couldn't have been that
good of a theory well that that's that's
those people honestly deserve to die in
a fire but but but
I think because you forget really
important [__] yeah really important
[__] yeah you put your bank password
that's so important yeah yeah all right
so all right right yeah it's like I mom
used to say that all the time I could
have been important that's like a saying
though that's one of those like what's
interesting is that people say that to
try to make you feel better yeah it
makes it worse it does yeah you're like
no it's important I was [__] thinking
of it yeah
uh and so
so now the guy has said Skip and I don't
know what he said and I'm pissed
skip I think he might have said it's
good it's good it wasn't that because I
would lean in and it was not that you're
just like
I skip I'll have the Bob's Big Boy you
leading real fast yeah Calvin does that
that's cute he leans into me cool man he
leans in a man he goes and he goes
he angles my head to watch something
watch watch this he goes wow yeah wow uh
so and then Bob's Big Boy uh the waiter
that I used to love all the time his
name was uh Kevin he was maybe 45.
um I loved that dude man we would we
would [__] and uh I found out years
later he died
of cancer
oh
I mean dude that is the worst that is
actually wait I'm thinking about it more
and more yeah that is the worst story
you could ever tell to like on a show
you know
I like comedy like that is just
unbelievably bad it was so sad nothing
good for about it he looked so like
healthy and [__] and he looked he was so
80s movie star he was good looking not
really but like nice looking you know he
died I I I stopped going to Bob's Big
Boy you know I moved it a little bit
further and then I came back one day and
I was like Hey so where's Kevin and
they're like oh really yeah like wow
okay geez yeah yeah I was reading about
a guy but anyway the skib is a thing
like slime
is and some of my friends what I skip is
I thought you know I don't know what a
skip is I don't like Bob's Big Boy and I
never did so why wouldn't it I don't
know it's gross
mentally or the duetes it tastes okay I
just yeah the vibe there is scary yeah
the vibe scary yeah it's like I would go
there outside the big boy outside like
with the gay the way you're saying it
the big boy outside yeah
uh all right man the big boy outside you
got to suck off
you know when you finish and you're like
a skip
are we doing one more or not no I mean
whatever dude but but also it's too hot
so that's cool okay so we'll turn let's
stop and then we'll take a take a little
cold air on us so far and yeah so
insecure the way you're laughing all
right cool well that's Lifeline we
appreciate you sign up for Lifeline
luxury there's an episode out today go
over to Lifeline luxury you go to
patreon.com Lifeline luxury why wouldn't
you put on the home screen that's crazy
and then uh you go uh you can see me in
Pittsburgh you see me in Cleveland you
see me in uh a bunch of different cities
chrisley.com gonna be at Fort Myers in
Orlando and reading and also
Philadelphia chrysalia.com if you got a
question go to the link below it's
watchlifeland.com or leave us a message
on the hotline it's below and uh send us
a video we love sending you we love
getting the videos man or follow-up
videos are great too you want a
one-on-one session no if you want a
one-on-one session you get go to
matalia.com book one with me yours truly
your secrets are safe with me I got the
merch lifelinemerch.com get every these
wear it every time you leave the house
because you never know when your house
so that could be cool yeah
you're coming off but and also leave a
message leave a message on under
underneath make a like like And
subscribe and all that stuff we love it
we love it when I was finishing you cut
me off it's all good but it was the very
end and you did that ah okay
[Music]